[Music]
all right so hello everybody uh my name
is Josh I'll be lecturing today
um so the topic of today's session is
going to be uh counter play I think a
lot of people out there end up uh
forgetting how chess is a practical game
at the end of the day and uh the
important thing in chess is to try to
make your opponent's life as hard as
possible because even if you lose
they'll feel bad when they win and
that's the important thing about Chess
so now let's take a look at a game where
I think that black did a really good job
of making sure that he was able to get
counter play even when uh White had a
fairly positionally dominant game the uh
from well it would have looked like it
would be a positionally dominant game
just from the opening position so let's
take a look so this is the game uh where
Yuri avrabach is playing white and Boris
vasky is playing Black this is from the
Soviet championship in 1956 for those
that you don't know the Soviet
championships back then were often
considered to be even stronger than a
lot of the international tournaments
like the inner zonals or the candidates
or things like this so let's take a look
so C4 from auberbach so we see a king's
Indian sabaski is a pretty uh
aggressive player so it can easily make
sense and of course Auerbach is playing
his own system with the Bishops on E2
and G5
the idea here for white is white is
simply trying to make some prophylaxis
against the E5 type of thing because uh
the bishop on G5 makes it so that this
type of counter play would not be
possible for black on account of Knight
D5 with a really devastating double
attack on F6 and C7
so um so C5 was played which is actually
still the main move today so but after
D5 but here the move that spaski chose a
little bit unusual uh Queen A5 a more
usual way for black to play is to play
something like H6 and then follow up
with like a very fast E6 basically no
matter where the bishop goes and you'll
end up with a sort of benoni situation
where the white Bishop is not in an
optimal Square
so Queen A5 Bishop D2 so our block is
just retreating and protecting the E4
Pawn A6 A4 so it's become very clear
that black is not going to be able to
play B5 and therefore this uh Queen
Excursion to A5 is probably not going to
be the most effective way to uh proceed
so and then so as you decide to play E5
so back then uh I think it would be a
lot more common for black to play with a
really closed Center like this I think
uh nowadays very few players would want
to do so uh as always the engines will
always hate Black's position here no
matter what
um I haven't looked at this game in some
time but I'm pretty sure that after
White's next move it's already uh like
plus two or something like that
um I think we can actually pause for a
second to think about what a white
should play in this position
maybe move the knight in preparation of
castling
yeah so so Knight F3 is is yeah
something like Knight of three would be
totally normal
um but overblock actually went for a
different plan here which I think is a
little bit better so uh so let's think
about firstly what does black want to do
in this position so Black's eventual
plan is that black is going to be
looking to play for uh F5 since that is
pretty much Black's only available Pawn
break in the position uh White has B5
covered way too well to uh to do
anything there so black will eventually
try to move the Knight and play F5 so
albertbach decides to go for profile
axis against this with moon G4 which uh
nowadays we actually know is a very uh
a common way in to to meet this idea of
F5
um white plays for this in against the
king's Indian a lot of the time nowadays
either with a fast H3 or a fast Bishop
E2 so in any case uh well spaski doesn't
have another plan so he just goes for 98
and we see a couple of moves so the idea
here is that White's not really so much
interested in delivering a Checkmate or
anything like that but just to close the
position and eventually utilize the
space advantage so here at G5 very nice
move from outer block and after Queen d8
Bishop G4 white is going to be able to
trade off the light Square Bishops which
is definitely a positional goal for
white in this Pawn structure with the uh
Pawn chains running the way that they do
so Knight C7 takes takes Knight F3 and
so in this position
um
black is having a lot of problems so to
start off with the uh black Bishop on G7
is more or less
uh at a pawn status it is not going to
be able to contribute much to this game
unless white for some reason opens the
position the Knight on C7 is also not
particularly placed in a great way it's
very common to put Knight on C7 in the
benoni structure to prepare B5 but again
that's there's just no way that's going
to happen and so black has a pretty
miserable position and it looks like
Sebastian's opening has been a complete
failure and he's going to lose the final
playoff against overbach and lose the
Soviet Championship so in this position
svasky decided to do something really
interesting so pretty much black has
like two choices in this position he can
choose to shuffle pieces around and
suffer until white makes some plan it
opens the king side and wins or you can
play the choose to play the move 96.
so uh
yeah it's not a great choice given that
uh given that uh we are giving up a
piece for almost nothing but this is a
really interesting moment because uh in
this position uh if you showed this game
to a computer the computer does not want
to play Knight C6 this position it
thinks is only plus five and Knight C6
thinks it's plus six
um unfortunately this doesn't really
matter for for real life yeah
um the uh the your opponent doesn't
really care what number it is your
opponent wants to feel safe when you're
winning you want to feel safe right
um everybody would prefer to win uh to
win without the opponent being able to
do anything rather than be able to win
some messy situation so what does the
move Knight C6 do well first of all if
white does nothing we can jump into that
D4 Square which is just absolutely
beautiful it's the more or less the only
good Square on the entire board for any
black knight and then from there it's
going to be able to exert some influence
over the position even then it doesn't
really do that much there but you know
it supports B5 and um it's definitely
annoying takes annoying for white takes
a lot squares away but of course the
critical test for white White's not
going to just ignore it white has to
take the Knight so after it takes takes
so now uh
it looks like we've given away a night
for nothing but the truth is that uh in
giving away our B8 right we've actually
significantly improved the Knight on C7
by allowing it to go to this really nice
Square on E6 so
um from from then we can go into D4 and
uh funnily enough it actually turns out
to be the white dark Square Bishop which
is a serious problem for white since it
doesn't really have the reasonable
squares on the board and um
yeah I mean again why does white is
still up at night
um and so it should still have a winning
position but this is very difficult for
white to play relative to the previous
situation just a couple of moves ago so
in a practical game it's very easy to
become uncomfortable with such things
and we will see how even overbach who is
probably one of the best players of all
time not to make it to the World
Championship
um is able to end up making some
mistakes here so Knight H4 very natural
to put pressure on G6
um this basket decides to defend with
Queen E8 and after it takes takes we see
Queen G4 so our buck is playing pretty
aggressively but as stated before with
the black pieces where they are
especially the bishop on G7
it does seem somewhat unlikely that
black is going to get checkmated but the
idea is not so much a Checkmate rather
than white just wants to create pressure
on the light squares
so Rook V8 uh Blaster simply developing
the rook and uh creating pressure down
the B file that B2 Pawn looks very weak
right now another very nice consequence
of our brilliant B take C6
so our back defends with Knight D1
the Knight on C3
another consequence of B take C6 nylon
C3 doesn't have anywhere to go so Knight
D1 makes sense
and from here we can see the knight jump
right into D4 so Rook H3
and so yeah it's kind of funny how like
just by removing the D5 Pawn or White's
position all of White's problems are
becoming exposed so like here for
example we'll see four Pawn this week
which besky is able to take advantage of
with Queen F7 and uh suddenly it's
actually a little bit annoying to play
for white
so our block went for Bishop C3
Bishop C3 here having a key idea here to
uh try to eliminate the Knight on D4
at the same time it's not really that
clear how much white really wants to do
that since black would be able to gain a
protected pass Pawn on D4 and then have
some somewhat mobile Pawn Mass with D5
and perhaps even opening up on that King
on E1 but uh Abu black has decided that
he doesn't really want to deal with this
Knight forever so he's going for Bishop
C3
rookie eight this move is a really nice
piece of prophylaxis because now if
white takes on D4 then after he takes D4
The Rook on E8 is already in the optimal
position and uh something like F3 would
allow uh perhaps D5 and White's position
is getting opened up probably a little
bit faster than he would want
so we have simply Rook H2 some
prophylaxis to try to hold the second
rank in the future so we have Queen
takes C4
Knight takes G6 and then Rook E6 so this
is a really interesting uh spot because
white actually has played this game very
well so far and in this position
actually can more and less deliver a
check made by force but the thing is
that uh do I think like spaski saw that
white could like reach a winning
position here probably but that's not
really the the point like
is down to piece he's going to lose
anyway if he doesn't try anything right
so
um by doing this he is forcing a lot of
pressure on white because white now has
a lot of pressure to calculate the
winning sequence which would start with
Rook h8
at the same time uh it's actually not a
trivial line at all
so we can just go through it together
but yes the best move here would be Rook
h8 because after it takes takes King G7
um
so Rook takes B8 is probably what
autoblock originally wanted to play and
why he didn't end up going for this line
but the truth is that white is actually
winning here even despite after F3 it
looks like there's no way for white to
prevent Queen E2 Checkmate but white has
the beautiful move Knight F4 he takes a
four and due to the pin Queen takes up
three is now possible with a winning
position for white
uh of course later on people figured out
that this is actually uh pretty much a
force Checkmate sequence but uh it's a
bit uh it's a bit silly for me
yes so we're turning back to the game we
have Bishop takes D4 which makes a lot
of sense since it's simply much safer
than what uh than the line with Rook h8
so after Bishop takes D4
but after Rook takes G6 now black has
not had to ruin the pawn structure and
uh move like Bishop C3 for white would
end up dropping the E4 pawn and then
from there black actually does have
legitimately
insanely dangerous compensation because
the central pawns are going to be
completely mobile like for example we
could just take a look at Bishop C3
takes King F1 even something like D5 and
this position is definitely not easy at
all for white to handle again this
bishop on G7 although although it's not
particularly active here it is doing an
amazing job of holding h8 and so
therefore it's going to be really
difficult for white to get in any sort
of Checkmate whereas the white king
turns out to be rather weak and the uh
Knight on D1 is not contributing much to
the game
so our Rock has gone for Queen F5
instead which also looks very attractive
um since the Rook is under attack which
allows white to force a trade of queens
and so again it looks like uh White is
just completely winning which uh
might be true but at the same time black
still is able to get a lot of counter
play here
um due to the nature of the center so
after D5 it turns out that the threat of
the coming D4 and C4 can be extremely
annoying for white to deal with in
particular we can notice how this Knight
on D1 is just really bad and it only
really serves this purpose by protecting
the B2 Pawn which is admittedly pretty
useful I mean white does need to protect
the B2 font but uh yeah it's definitely
not in the optimal position
so we have F3 just protect the E4 upon
and now uh so it's possible to start
with D4 but spaski actually went for
Rook B3 so first of all just improving
the position of the rook and secondly
creating some pressure on F3 so now D4
is actually threatening to win that F3
Pawn
so Rook B3 Rook H3 so it's never a good
sign when you have to play Rook H3 Rook
H2 and then Rook H3 back
um so yeah anyway Rook H3 is forced to
protect the F3 Pawn
and again it's possible to start with D4
but it's not 100 obvious that uh that we
have anything specific here so
decides to start with C4 instead
um just to maintain some more
flexibility in the position
King D2 and uh yeah it's pretty clear
that even though white does have the
extra piece it's definitely black who
has the initiative here so you can see
after Rook G6 uh White doesn't want to
get the G5 Pawn of course so we see Rook
G1 D4 Bishop A5 and yeah suddenly I
don't even think uh White even has an
objective Advantage anymore the
position is is really tough now
um which is amazing because it doesn't
even appear to me like white has made
any particularly obvious uh positional
mistake or anything like this
um
but yeah after uh
after Bishop A5 we see that in this
position black doesn't really have too
many other pieces to improve both Rooks
are under optimal positions and it looks
like the black pawns are perfect but we
always go through worst piece first and
we know that since white does not have
the battery on the H file anymore we are
free to release the G7 Bishop from its
job at protecting h8 and Bishop f8 so
now if white moves the Bishop from A5 we
can have the potential to jump into B4
or C5 or something like this uh we see
Randy has suggested Bishop F6 in the
chat which is probably also possible
um
yep probably this is possible I think
that uh White probably is able to trade
the Rooks with Rook H6 or something like
this and this is probably why uh spaski
didn't end up going for it but
definitely also makes a lot of sense and
this is probably also not super bad for
black or anything like this since we are
going to be picking up the H6 pawn and
again I doubt white has a big Advantage
if anything at all so Bishop F6 would
also have been possible but Bishop f8 I
would say that uh with regard to
practical chess I think that somehow
holding tension always benefits the side
who is making the choice to hold it
since you're it feels kind of
uncomfortable to play against with the
opponent like this you know so and
especially when you're down material you
want to be trading too much so that's
probably why vishwefe was preferred
Rook G4 so and now we have Rook D6 just
making that King on D2 feel just a
little bit uncomfortable and there are
some potential threats of C3 to open up
some files on the queen side
King C2
Rook D7 so now spaski is working on
improving this Rook which wasn't doing
too much on D6 or G6 now that white has
protected the G5 pawn and so now he just
wants to double up on the B file and
look for some sort of C3 D3 type of
breakthrough
so G6 Rook B7
overblock finally decides that his
Bishop on A5 is too bad where it is so
he just goes back to E1
C5 Rook to H4 Bishop G7 and we can tell
how uncomfortable our buck is with his
position by seeing that he played Bishop
A5 in this position
so yeah even here uh if black were to
play something like Bishop F6 and just
completely wait
um it still seems like white is going to
be having a good position here
um because at the end of the day white
is up at night and so with the King on
C1 the idea here for white would be to
shift the Rook back to the second Rank
and perhaps look for some development of
the knight in the future although it is
admittedly very difficult for uh for for
what
for white to get into that sort of
position
so yeah it definitely would still be
tough but
black should not be playing slowly in
the situation when you're down at night
so now in this position sebasti decides
that it is the time to go for the
Breakthrough with C3
so after Pawn takes C3 at first it looks
like there isn't really that concrete of
a follow-up and the point is after okay
three black has two ideas here the A4
Pawn is extremely loose and also Rook A2
is going to be coming in with a powerful
attack on the white king in the near
future so she takes D4
in this position the material is not
really the foremost of Black's concerns
so uh
C takes D4 would definitely not be right
and E takes D4 is important so we just
want to be adding some attackers to the
game with our pawn and D4 and our new
pawn on C4 coming very soon
Rook takes F4 we have Rook A2 p and D3
and Rook B1 and suddenly it just looks
like white is being completely swamped
here and after Rook H1 takes this
position definitely seems to be
extremely difficult for white so King C2
Rook B5 and OtterBox decides to go for a
last-ditch effort with E5
so in this position
um
it is a bit difficult to choose from
Black's various good looking options at
this point
if black wants to play for some for to
take the bishop then there may be some
E6 type of counter play
[Music]
um
and uh the right way for black to play
in this position is Bishop takes E5 and
follow up with C4 and in fact to
actually take none of the available
pieces and simply just keep pressing
onward with the attack which is a little
bit hard to believe but a very beautiful
Concept in Chess at least
um instead spaski decided to go for D3
which also looks very attractive since
we are picking up that Rook on f4 on
account of the
um
Discovery but the problem is that uh
yeah probably my guess is that spaski
wasn't really thinking about playing too
hard for a win at this point I mean he
has been down to piece the entire game
so after D3 uh we see a lot of
simplification and unfortunately this
position is not really possible to to
win which I also found hard to believe
at first since uh well it isn't the
exchange and the pawn right but it turns
out that the white pieces are just way
too active here so suddenly it's been
like a sort of flip of what's been
happening the entire game where um
uh where black has been the one down
material in exchange for a great amount
of counter play and uh now we actually
have the complete opposite case where
white is the one down material but white
has a ton of counter play and so after
like a ton of moves they eventually
agreed to a draw and these none of these
moves are particularly important to our
theme or anything like that just kind of
amusing that this is theoretically uh
drawn and we end up with this funny
position where this is drawn because
black does not have a way to activate
the king past the fifth rank without
giving up the B5 Pawn
so yeah basically I just want to draw
everyone's attention to uh this move uh
Knight C6 which ended up changing the
course of the game entirely I'd imagine
that by the time ABY block was in this
position with Knight F3 he was just
thinking about how uh the game is
probably going to feel pretty good from
here it doesn't really seem obvious how
black can make any sort of counter play
and
yeah it and whenever your opponent is
thinking about something like this it's
your job to make sure your opponent
doesn't feel comfortable and that you
want to create as many chances as
possible and it turns out that from here
Sebastian was actually able to even
outplay Auerbach and um
even reach a winning position at one
point although not without some help
from his opponent of course but that's
what chess is all about you know nobody
can win without help from their opponent
okay so let's move on to another game
now
all right so uh in this game in
particular this is a game that I played
with black
um and so
I mostly want to bring the attention to
one specific point in the game
um so we can just quickly go through the
opening moves which uh
I would say that I played pretty well
for the first couple of moves but then
after that it got pretty bad very fast
so it looks like I'm achieving a lot in
this sort of hanging Pawn structure but
turns out I've given up a lot of key
squares
so in this position uh I believe the
right way for white to continue is with
E4 and it's very unobvious to me how I
should actually be meeting this sort of
breakthrough on account of my various
undefended pieces in the in the center
but Knight B5 is also very attractive
with this specific idea uh right I
believe that here is the moment when E4
is also strong so but after Queen E5 we
see white has gone for a really
interesting sacrifice here with Knight
takes up seven
so Knight takes five seven is a really
interesting move because I don't know
about you but in this position I didn't
even see that move was legal like he
played it and I like jumped out of my
chair which is uh not ideal when you're
playing chess you don't want to be
jumping when you're playing chess so uh
yeah after Knight takes F7 whenever your
opponent plays a move that you don't
expect there's a couple of steps you
need to go through the first one you
need to determine what is the opponent's
idea so if they're sacrificing a piece
the first thing you got to think about
is all right well what is what is he
going to do if I just simply take the
piece so what happens if black takes
Knight so King takes F7
96 is a very natural check to Fork the
king and Rook but unfortunately for
black that is that is not all like after
a move like uh King G7 I would be very
happy if white were to take the rook and
then I'm pretty comfortable here given
that I do have two Knights versus The
Rook which is generally a fit not
unfavorable material imbalance
but white actually has something even
stronger here with um simply 98 and
after King F7 capturing the F6 Knight
and
despite only being up upon the problem
the central Palm for black is that uh
I'm going to be checkmated very soon so
this is not acceptable so
um and the other king moves such as king
f8 suffers from another problem which is
much more beautiful I think the simple
Queen E6 with a double threat of Queen
F7 Checkmate and Bishop takes F6 and it
is not possible for black to defend
against both threats simultaneously
so I realized oh no like my opponent
sacrificed to peace and I can't take it
so in this position uh and obviously we
can't simply leave it there uh if we're
white to move white would capture the
bishop on d8 sorry uh that's not what I
meant to do so in this position white
would simply capture the bishop on d8
and then there would be no defense along
the long diagonal so with black it's
very important to look for some resource
that might uh not lose a Tempo or
something and uh or perhaps an
intermediate move is the right word
we're looking for
so Knight D7 is the only move here
but it still appears that black is
losing so it's really important to
understand uh how to continue so white
obviously does not have the idea of just
moving the queen away and dropping the
Knight again Knight D6 is possible but
uh but in this position black is still
able to gain the favorable material and
balance and in fact I believe Black's
even able to trap the White Queen
immediately with Bishop C7 and I really
don't think that my opponent who is a
strong IM of 2480 was going to play in
such a way with that idea in mind
so Knight H6 comes and so now the key
for black is to make the decision
between putting the King on G7 or f8
um
so it is a somewhat uh difficult
decision since it looks like King G7 is
more natural
um as we're trying to create pressure on
the Knight
um
but there's a specific idea that black
has in mind that is very important to
understanding this position and is a
little bit uh difficult to understand so
in the case of King G7 I believe white
is playing uh Queen G3
or something and after King takes
um
there is some idea here
okay perhaps I should uh perhaps I
should actually figure out what the idea
is when I say it I used to know but it's
been a while I believe in the game I was
most concerned about Queen G5 actually
with the threats of uh Knight F5 coming
was the problem
um so like most of the moves I want to
play about white snipe to escape through
F5 and therefore I didn't really want to
do that
um
there are also lots of threats for white
involving E4 trying to open up the
center given that the
white Bishop is exerting a lot of
pressure on the diagonal so yes Queen G5
and following up with Knight F5 would
definitely be not what I was looking for
so the key here is to play the very
awkward looking with King f8 and at
first it doesn't look right for black at
all but the thing is that uh
white actually has a big source of
trouble on the queen side so a move like
uh Queen F4 for example uh actually
allows black a pretty nice resource here
with Queen B8 and it looks incredibly
strange but after the exchange of Queens
white doesn't really have a great way of
saving the B5 Knight without dropping
the B3 Palm
I briefly considered this situation in
the game but I realized that the uh not
on H6 is actually completely trapped so
King G7 would simply pick it up here
and so this was actually the idea that
led me to solving the problem in the
game situation so I had already seen
what was likely to happen in the game
when I had played King f8 but the idea
is very important to know
um
before going into it so
uh Queen G5 is a more natural Square for
the White Queen since it doesn't come
under attack by Queen V8
um but believe it or not in this
position White's attack is actually not
going to
come to a fruition like this because the
White Knight on H6 remains absolutely
terrible and there isn't really a great
way for white to free it here
so the key here for black of course we
must act fast so as with white to move
we would simply play something like
Knight G4 and the Knight would escape
and we're left with a pawn down and very
bad King so the key here starts with
queen B8
and after it takes takes Knight C3 right
so this is the key position uh actually
not 100 sure if my opponent had seen
this in advance
um but yeah so we already know that the
key for black revolves around this H6
Knight being very weak and so uh all
these moves prior had all been setting
up for this move Knight G8 and rather
unbelievably the uh White Queen is
actually not able to hold on to the
Knight no matter what because of the
queen V8 so uh yeah Queen B7 here would
not achieve the same effect because in
this position
um the queen would simply go to be free
to go to F4 so yeah unfortunately for me
I actually was not able to win because
white is able to pick up the C pawn and
then this is somehow drawn or something
like that but um
yeah definitely a situation where uh
where I consider it to be a pretty
decent uh calculation here and I think
also a reminder of how important it is
to stay calm when your opponent is doing
something that you're not expecting
all right
okay so all right so this is a game
which uh is a little bit embarrassing in
actually several different ways so in
this game I'm playing White against uh
bruzon uh Lazaro bruzon Batista that is
a very strong player he used to be over
2700 one of the best players in the
world
um so this was my second time playing
him actually
or yeah it was my second time playing
him I've actually played him four times
and we've drawn all four times but uh
it's always been scary playing against
him is what I'll say
so in this game I'm playing a white
so we have the Italian game which I
played pretty much all the time back
then Knight of six so so far everything
looks pretty normal
uh A4 is a pretty normal way for white
to handle the position as well simply
preparing the A2 Square as a retreat for
the bishop A5 C3 and here Lazaro
surprises me with move th8 so th8 is
normally associated with the idea of
moving the Knight to G8 and then
following up with F5 which can sometimes
be a good plan but in my experience it's
usually not that dangerous for white
because black is uh
undeveloping a lot of pieces and
therefore opening the center is very
strong so might be two and I wasn't
really that concerned about Knight G8
here since I just felt okay so I'll
simply play D4 and I think black is
probably not going to play F5 here on
account of the central weakening
but instead Zara has chosen a better way
to uh
reroute the knights Knight 97. uh insane
lonely bear asks if I would prefer the
Roy Lopez now I don't really have a
preference I don't like playing against
E4 E5 so let's just say that uh
I'm sure why not
so 97 uh right so okay I figured well
all right black is still trying to play
F5 so I would just play D4 Knight B6 and
then Bishop B5
okay so this looks uh pretty nice so far
and after he takes D4 I developed some I
do some really clever idea but
unfortunately my idea was way too clever
here so at first when I had gone into
this position I'd thought about okay
like I'll simply take on D4 and after
Knight takes D4 so he takes D4 uh right
so naturally we'd want to take on D4
with the pawn but I thought after Knight
B4 or something like this uh the black
knives can be really annoying on V4 so I
thought okay I should take for the
Knight instead
um but I figured after C6 or something
and then uh black can even play like D5
here and yeah I just didn't really feel
too confident in this position uh maybe
White's a little better maybe white
isn't but I just wasn't really too sure
about playing into this Pawn structure
so then I was thinking about okay well
imagine if I took on C6 first like after
Pawn takes C6 then I take on D4 this way
and I have my ideal Pawn Center there's
no night before uh Black's definitely
got some weak pawns on C6 which I'm
going to be targeting with Queen C2 and
I'll follow up with Knight F1
and my position everything flows
together very harmoniously and so yeah I
was I was definitely really excited to
to play into this and so therefore I
actually did take on C6
but uh unfortunately I should have
realized that my opponent he was 26 50
feet is not going to Simply let me do
that and when he took on C3 I was uh
definitely not happy with with what had
happened is what I would say
um
I think I was pretty I was pretty upset
here and I think for like maybe five
seconds I was thinking about resigning
but I don't think I can resign on move
12 as white so uh I had to think about
the best way to continue here
um so of course Black's idea is that
he's attacking both minor pieces and it
is not possible for white to move both
of them away at the same time and uh
pretty much no matter what white is
going to be doing here black is going to
be up with an extra Pawn since black has
captured two pawns and we have yet to
capture any back
so in this position the key here is that
uh so even though my position is really
bad and I figured I'm probably going to
lose
um
again we want to make the opponent
uncomfortable so you won't so we have to
play in the best way possible so that uh
our opponent finds the conversion
difficult so after Pawn takes C3 we see
uh uh so I don't really want to take
back on C3 since after take C6 in this
position not only does black have that
same extra Pawn black even has the
bishop pair and uh it's very unobvious
to me how I'm going to continue playing
with this Pawn structure my Pawn CS3 is
not impressive and but I can simply
develop this way and if anything black
is one with the initiative after a
potential F5 in the future and I'm just
not really too sure where to put any of
my pieces so definitely uh with white
you want to be preserving the two
Bishops here with Bishop B5 so he takes
D2 Bishop takes two so I figure okay
well if you're going to take my extra
Pawn I might as well get some
development out of it
so C6
um Bishop E2 I chose Bishop E2 over
Bishop D3 because I was concerned about
some uh D5 stuff and uh I thought that I
didn't want my Bishop to uh be on the
Xposed D file when this happens
so I went for Bishop E2
so my idea was to meet D5 with Queen C2
and recapture on e4 with the queen
and from here I was thinking okay well
it's probably not like good for me or
anything but uh if anything this was
visually imposing uh like my I feel like
uh against a lesser opponent maybe
they'll just run into this sort of thing
and uh perhaps lose quickly and I'll be
able to save some face
but unfortunately it brazon is not going
to let that happen so he starts with
Bishop F6
and in this position uh Bishop D3 is
possible to start with but after G6
Black's actually threatening to win my
or when a decisive amount of material
with Bishop F5 which would uh cause me
to lose my Bishop on D3 so I decided to
start with Rook ad1 which is also very
natural
um now if uh black does nothing I'm
probably just going to take the pawn in
A5 using the discovery so black is going
to have to protect it
he ends up starting with rookie eight
just to get the queen out of the way I
mean because black doesn't really lose
anything from doing so and continues
with Knight D5
so again another very tough situation
um where you're down a pond and there's
not really too much to do
um so right now my immediate problem is
that uh this Black Knight on D5 is super
strong so I need to be able to figure
out something that I can do against this
Knight on D5
so I've decided to remove it even if I
have to trade some pieces so I've
started with Bishop C3
and after it takes takes so now at least
I'm threatening C4 and uh on paper at
least this doesn't look so bad because
Black's Queen side majority uh well he's
got three pawns and we have two
unfortunately usually here we would have
a king size majority there but not
possible in this case
um
but yeah it's gonna be very difficult
for black to push these pawns since uh
black we need to do so with B5 at some
point
um but we have our A4 Pawn here to stop
that from happening with our Bishop and
most likely to have a knight on D4 so in
this position white is immediately
threatening C4 to take advantage of this
pin so uh black moves the queen to F6
which is the optimal Square since it is
putting pressure on the C3 Pawn as well
now I definitely don't want to be
playing C4 so I'll end up giving this B4
Square to the Black Knight where it's
just absolutely brilliant here and my
light scribbishop is definitely going to
be suffering a lot
so we have Knight D4
and so here again I was kind of feeling
like good probably a bit too eager but I
was thinking like okay well black
doesn't have any way to do all the
bishop so I don't even know how they'll
actually continue but of course he just
plays Bishop D7 and some regular moves
and I decided to go for Queen B3 just
making some pressure on B7 Rook B8
and so now we can look at this position
so now we're just looking at this
position we can tell that most of white
species are actually placed pretty well
unfortunately uh it isn't in the cost of
a pond which is not ideal but so most of
white spaces are placed pretty well but
one of them is not really doing anything
right now and that piece is the bishop
on E2 so I ended up going to F3 with the
vain hope that he was going to let me
take on D5 of course he's not going to
but the bishop is still improved on F3
no matter what so it takes takes
and bruzon finds a really nice way to
improve the Knight with Knight F4
so it turns out that the threat of the
Knight going to D3 is actually quite
uncomfortable
so
here I ended up playing Rook B1 so Rook
B1 is simply just improving my rook and
getting out of the way of a potential
Knight D3
but here uh I didn't really take the
move that razan ended up playing very
seriously but after he played it I
realized that it was actually extremely
uncomfortable to meet
so uh in this position
played the move C5 so originally I was
thinking okay well this doesn't really
look that impressive for for black to me
um like it just feels like bikes giving
up the B5 square and exposing the B7
Pawn
um
but the truth is that the positioning of
my pieces makes it so that black has a
lot of potential threats on the king
side such as with Knight H3 since I will
have to let go of the bishop with my
knight
um I believe Knight B5 is not ideal
because of associated tactics so I ended
up having to go to C2 but still I was
hoping okay well you know if I can post
now on E3 maybe I can jump into D5 at
some point uh maybe even like Knight C4
and Target the A5 Pawn at some point in
the future so yeah I was still not super
worried then he played Bishop F5
and then I was thinking okay
um well my night's pinned so that's
definitely not ideal so I have to move
it away rookie one
Knight D3 yeah unfortunately now from
here Black's pieces all come together
very nicely with Tempo further proof
that my opponent is drawing GM Rook F1
should D5 and now an excellent move C4
to secure that D3 Square forever so it
looks like uh like I was doing pretty
well and suddenly I am not
um but yes after Bishop D3 rookie one
Queen D6 93 so in this position uh black
was actually getting a little bit short
of time which is a really important
factor that I feel like people don't
really discuss quite enough
um
in standard games particularly those
that are around 90 30 time is actually a
very serious Factor at least for me
um
and so it's really important that like
when we get counter play another really
reason another reason why it's so good
to do so is because usually you're able
to put your opponent on clock pressure
we always say that it's easier to attack
than defend and that's just another
application of how that goes
so we have 93 and queen C5 and here I
decided that I need to set a trick
because black is going to play B5 pretty
much no matter what happens
and if black plays B5 then
um
then the A4 Pawn is going to disappear
and the black a pawn is just going to be
free to go and we won't be able to do
too much about it
so I decided to set a little trap here
so I'd start with H3 to just free up the
back rank since I know that's going to
be a problem after the B file comes open
so B5 takes takes all right so here
there's a really interesting Crossroads
although it may not seem like it like if
you looked at this specific position
with a computer you would actually never
even know because pretty much everything
is about equally losing here in terms of
objectivity
so in this position my original
intention was to play Queen A2
and so this move Queen A2 I thought okay
well this looks pretty good actually
because I'm putting pressure on C4 and
my pressure on C4 means that I'm
threatening F4
and I'm also threatening to take on C4
since black has a back rank problem in
the the end so a move like uh Rook B3
um what about Bishop takes C4 Bishop
takes C4 Knight takes C4 and yeah
Black's gonna have to let go of one of
the pieces here although it looks a
little bit strange so so okay so I was
thinking all right so that looks good so
how else can black protect the beat the
C4 Pawn since F4 is very important then
I realized that black can actually solve
the back rank problem and the threat of
f4 in a single move which is the move G5
and this move is very important for
black
um and then I realized after G5 I
actually don't really have any way to
get counter play whatsoever it looks a
little bit odd for black to uh make the
king like to expose the king like this
but what I was realizing was that yeah
there's just no way I can take advantage
of my pieces where they are uh my knight
on E3 blocks my Rook but it's needed to
protect my Bishop so I I can't really
rearrange my pieces in any way and I
figured that if this happened uh most
likely I was just going to lose because
I'm down the a pawn and literally all my
pieces are worse than literally all the
black pieces so
then when I started thinking about was
setting another trap with a different
move Queen D2 and the trap here is that
after Queen D2
um
so unlike Queen A2 this move doesn't
actually have a super strong direct
threat beyond the back rank so black
should simply play something like H6
because in the case of f4 there's no
longer pressure on C4 so black can
simply retreat with Knight G6 or
something like this
but if black does play G5 which he ended
up doing because he was short of time
then after G5 black suddenly has a
really serious problem
um
so G5 turns out to be a horrible move
here but so that's like another point
that I want to bring up with the point
is to uh
is to uh try to make Black's life
difficult right so Queen I2 uh yeah I
know that Black's gonna see G5 uh and so
after Queen D2 uh most likely or I
shouldn't say most likely but there's a
solid chance that he'll just do the same
thing thinking that F4 is still a
serious threat especially with low time
so after G5 so why is G5 so bad well the
key lies with the queen being on D2 so
as we just talked about with the queen
on A2 there wasn't really a way to get
the pieces into attack the black king
since the uh actually we can just go
back to the position real quick so
there's no way to reroute the pieces to
attack the black king since um we would
need at least a couple of moves to bring
our Queen in and then move the Knight
somewhere but the bishop will always be
hanging when we do that
but in the case of Queen D2 G5 ROM USCF
does have the right idea where the move
Knight takes C4
so first of all after Bishop takes C4
now white takes an E5 and funnily enough
taking the bishop here would actually
lose because after game G7 black is
getting checked made up by Queen takes
G5 which is very sad
so black needs to take with a knight and
of course I was not going to play Queen
takes D3 since here Queen takes D5 is
simply possible
um and also rookie eight looks cool but
after rookie eight uh there is just King
G7 and unfortunately we have not
eliminated the D3 Bishop so black is
able to just play Bishop G6
and it looks like black is still winning
so the key here when something doesn't
work is you try to figure out if you can
flip the move order so Queen takes G5
and in this case if black wants the
bishop G6 hoping to transpose to the
previous variation of the important move
for white is to start with Queen F6 to
prevent black from playing king of G7
and then rookie 8 will simply win on the
back rank
so in this position what black should
play as Queen f8 to just hold the back
Rank and prevent any of this rookie 8
sort of nonsense as well as uh hold F7
and in this position what I was going to
do was I was just simply going to repeat
moves with Queen G5 and I would have
been very happy with that uh after all
my opponents not only much power rated
than me but uh also I've just been down
upon the whole game and I'm very happy
to have this lucky break I believe
actually uh Queen D4 is supposed to be
like maybe even like slightly better for
white but uh
um yeah I was not going to be pressing
my luck here so yeah in the case of
Queen f8 I would definitely have just
repeated moves no questions asked
and instead on move 38 so two moves
before the timing control finally cracks
with the move
um
Knight D6
and uh so here is a moment where I
myself am rather low on time and I did
something that was uh pretty
embarrassing so in this position I think
it's definitely not the most challenging
Mateen 3 I've ever seen to have rookie
eight Knight takes E8 Queen takes F7 and
queen G8 but unfortunately in this
position I had like five minutes left
and I spent like three of them
calculating the move Queen takes E8 so
I'm sure that you understood where I was
had to mentally at this point so uh in
the game I decided to just simply take
on F7 first and play rookie 8. so I'm
just winning the queen here
and so I'm actually not up any material
here I have a queen in two pawns versus
a rook and two minor pieces which is
very rarely a favorable imbalance for
the side with the queen but the problem
for black is that the Pieces Just Don't
coordinate at all since the Knight is
needed to protect the king so
even this position is still completely
winning for white even though I have
just uh blundered away uh fourth
Checkmate which is kind of sad which I
actually didn't realize during the game
after the game a lot of my friends came
up and told me like did you see the mate
and I was like what are you talking
about I didn't believe there was one but
uh yeah chess is a hard game
so after game G7
um so I figured okay I'm probably still
winning here because uh again the black
pieces don't coordinate and black
shouldn't be able to reliably stop the C
Pawn so in the game present here went
for Rook B1 and then Bishop Z2
C4 A4
and yeah so this was another uh step in
my sequence of questionable choices so
after C5 A3
uh I'm not sure exactly what I missed
but uh simply Queen A7 is very winning
here since black dust doesn't have any
reasonable way to continue pushing the
pawn uh if I want to defend it with like
Rook B3 or something then simply C6 is
possible and there's there's not really
going to be any way for black to stop
the C Pawn without giving up uh a minor
piece
so in this instead I decided to go for
C6 and we reached this really bizarre
spot with uh where we're going to be
both promoting I don't know exactly what
I missed I believe maybe it was that
black that Bishop G6 is a legal move in
this position
um but yeah this was like after the time
control so there's really no excuse we
had already had time added to our clocks
and therefore there's no time excuse or
anything like that so definitely I
should have been calculating better here
but yes after Queen G4 Bishop G6 C8
Queen this is actually a situation where
uh I mean it's not something you get
every day this material imbalance so
that was kind of nice to see and this is
definitely one of the most fun games
I've had in my career but uh this is
definitely a a place where white is the
one who needs to be more careful since
after all black is the one that is
delivering the attack now
so Busan starts with H5 to sort of
dislodge this queen on G4 Queen F4 is
absolutely necessary
because otherwise the threat of Rook H1
followed by King G3 Queen E5 is
extremely dangerous
so instead I've went for a queen F4 to
prevent this
okay H1 King G3
Queen A3 yeah so everything here is is
definitely very very scary looking so
for example a move like Queen F3 would
actually be losing since I would end up
having to let go of my queen after
something like King G4 and Bishop H5 and
this should be losing for white so yeah
definitely a very risky situation so I
have to go for F3 not a move I was super
thrilled about for sure since I'm
exposing my king a lot if black was able
to move the queen to E1 in one move I
would actually just lose immediately
which is definitely not the ideal
situation of course
so Queen A1
and unfortunately the game now turns
very ordinary very fast since I will
have to return my queen on well my C8
Queen sorry I'll have to return my C8
Queen to the uh defense of my king and
yeah there's
uh situation where pretty soon I will
have to trade the Queens with uh queen
ff6 always fun to say that so I'll try
to do that as much as I can so yeah
Queen ff6 and uh so now I'm creating my
own mate threats to force black to
exchange the Queens with Queen E1 King
F4 and then Queen C1
yeah and unfortunately black is able to
trade off the B2 Queen so after it takes
takes and G4 yeah so unfortunately so I
tried to press this for a little while
um but the central problem for black or
for white rather is that uh queen and a
single Pawn versus the rook and Knight
is not going to be enough to win so all
black really needs to do in this
situation is to just keep the pieces
tight and sacrifice the bishop for one
of the pawns so this is how it ended up
happening in the game and after Rook G6
there's just not a reasonable way for
white to break this Fortress since the
threats to the F to the G5 Pawn are
always going to be way too serious and
we ended up making a draw here
but yeah so I think this is a really
good example of how like playing in a
resourceful way and looking for ways to
uh trick your opponent or surprise your
opponent when you're losing is a really
important factor in getting the best
practical results
uh I don't do we have time to do
anything else in four minutes uh let's
see
oh okay
um
yeah okay so uh yeah I think we can do
like a bit of an exercise here so this
is from another game where I played
um
yeah so here we have a bit of an
exercise so
um
all right so we have this position where
it is Black Taboo
so this is from a game I played in 2018
so I was not a GM and I didn't even have
any egm Norms actually so my opponent
with playing the white pieces is a
Camilo Dragon a Polish Grandmaster who I
believe lives in the United States right
now
um he actually won the Polish
championship in that year so it's a very
uh scary opponent so in this position I
had no idea what I was doing in the
opening and I've just simply set up all
the normal Hedgehog Moves while white
has positioned all of his pieces in
order to Checkmate me so definitely not
the most uh ideal situation so in this
position what I figured was probably
going to happen is that well if I don't
do anything so immediately white is
actually threatening G5 which would uh
create a serious problem against the
Knight on F6 and unlike the normal
Hedgehog I can't simply just play Knight
C5 or something since there's a really
well placed Pawn on B4 so in this
position it is Black's job to survive
that and so how should I like uh Stave
off the attack
maybe we can take some suggestions from
the audience
Martin plus two suggests D5 which is
definitely one of the ideal moves for
black in the Hedgehog unfortunately we
just don't have enough pieces behind it
white can simply play E5 and after
Knight E4 we're going to be dropping the
d-pawn and we're just going to be
totally losing here
um yeah and a lot of the other moves
suggested are also sensible uh someone
suggested King h8 which is possible but
this is definitely not one of the
situations you're really happy with with
black for for sure nice on G8 black just
doesn't really have any active play and
white can even continue with something
like H4 and it I find it very hard to
believe that black is going to survive
for very long
um so H6 was a common suggestion but
after white plays H4 white is still
going to be playing G5
um but H6 is actually still fine as long
as it has the same idea as the game
which features G5
um
so the reason I say that H6 is also fine
it's because after H4 G5 is still
acceptable for for black with the the
exactly the same idea but the reason G5
is so strong is that uh the black king
is not really becoming exposed here
um and after F takes G5 we see Knight E5
and uh in the game I don't know why
Dragon gave up the E4 Pawn but here I've
reached a better position and even won
the game but white should probably play
Queen D4 and I had already first seen
this position and I thought this was
definitely very unclear it turns out to
be relatively fine for black but uh I
didn't really think about this when I
was in the game
so the reason that that uh this move is
interesting is because it actually loses
by force to the move Knight cd5 which I
didn't really fully understand I did
believe that white was able to make some
sacrifices because my king was so
exposed like this
um but the point is that uh this is
actually not important to playing the
move G5 the important thing is that in
this position just like with the
Auerbach and spaski game
um
uh as with the move Knight C6 uh it
doesn't particularly matter whether the
move is engine best or whatever the
important thing is that you're turning a
situation where you have no chances into
a situation where you have chances and I
think that's probably about it for
today I would love to go through some of
the details but perhaps we don't have
time
okay sure
um yeah so it's very difficult to
convince people that icd5 is winning by
force but the truth is that this
position white just has insane
compensation
um the problem for black is that there's
just not really any reasonable way to
stop this very slow maneuver which will
win the game
the majority of the black pieces like
the queen on A8 and the bishop on B7 are
just completely not playing the game
um there isn't really like a concrete
lines here or anything like this to to
demonstrate this but I didn't even
have full knowledge of this in the game
as well so I guess you could say I'm uh
perhaps a little bit unlucky but it
doesn't actually matter because if white
has to fight night cd5 that's already a
big step from this position where it
just seems like we're losing no matter
what so
again another situation where G5 is not
considered best by the engine at all but
I think G5 is the only or perhaps H6
followed by G5 is the only real idea to
stay in the game as black and after I've
takes g595 yeah so Queen D4 would be the
challenging way to meet it and there's
actually a ton of moves for black I was
probably just going to play Bishop f8
um and I figured that eventually I would
just rearrange the pieces like this and
realistically speaking I actually have
no idea what plan white is going for now
since the king side attack has been
completely stopped and the side on D5 is
just an absolute Rock it's never going
to be able to be moved by white
um it turns out there's a lot of like
funny computer lines I thought this one
was was hilarious
um so if white takes there's a threaded
Knight takes F3 so black is able to pick
up the H4 Pawn
um and so white needs to find Knight cd5
or something and uh there's some
beautiful Perpetual check this is
actually one of the most the only reason
I'm bringing this up is because this is
probably the most beautiful approachable
check I've ever seen in my life
um but yes after Queen G6 can you check
Queen H5 and the black king is not able
to touch the G7 Square I think Knight F5
so black will end up uh having to agree
to the Perpetual king of Fate nine to
five is the same with the checkmate so
yeah so just wanted to show that
um and after B5 is probably the best
move with the idea C takes B5 Bishop d8
which uh probably I didn't understand
and would not have played
um but yes the idea of Bishop B6 is very
strong
so white would have to do something like
this and yeah everything seems to work
out for black but none of these lines
are really important I would just play
Bishop f8 it just had a fairly normal
position so yeah believe it or not after
F takes G5 the position is actually
already not great for white and what's
interesting is that after F takes G5 my
Dragoon had actually offered me a draw
which uh
I don't know if you are aware from
practical experience when a highly rated
player offers you draw it usually means
that they're not comfortable with what
they have so even though the position
was equal probably he was already not
feeling too great about the position and
so that's another key factor of playing
in such a way where even though it's
technically losing it's really important
to try to go for something and my
suspicion was confirmed when he played
Queen E2 after Knight takes E4 the
position is just simply good for black
and eventually I managed to uh win the
game after some long Adventures which we
don't have time for but yes
all right thank you
[Music]